Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This absurd is brought to you by four sigmatic,
founded by the Genius Fin's who lit the Internet on fire and you may have heard
of their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every day,
either that or the Chaga,
which is decaf as a separate version,
and I use both of these primarily for focus and productivity.
They just get you going let you up like a Christmas tree,
so definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer.
I try to force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing if I have employees or people come over who are working
on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their product sold out in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with hot water.
And oddly enough,
only includes 40 milligrams of caffeine.
So it has less than half of what you would get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters,
acid reflux or any stomach burn,
any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option.
And I have a cupboard full of their products,
uh,
at the moment,
which is right around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something,
you can try a sample pack,
which is great.
Also right now by going to foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim,
that's foursigmatic,
I g,
m,
a t,
I c.
Dot com forward slash Tim and use the Code Tim Tim to get 20% off of your first
order and they're not that expensive anyway.
If you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed,
so try them out.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day.
As listeners of the Tim Ferriss,
you can receive 30% off of your first order by visiting Athletic greens.com
forward slash Tim that is a great deal on one of my favorite products and it
covers my basis.
Each day is part of my routine and it leaves me with less to worry about.
If for instance,
I have to skip a meal or just can't get a high quality meal,
so check it out.
Go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim and learn all about it.
I know my little Munchkins,
boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is always my job to deconstruct world class performers,
to share the thinking,
the habits,
the tips and tricks that you can apply in your own life,
whether those people come from the worlds of sports,
from chess,
from entertainment,
and in this case from investing.
I'm very,
very excited about this conversation that you are about to hear.
I had a blast.
It is with Ray Daleo who has been called the Steve jobs of investing and we'll
get to why that is the case.
This is Ray's first longform podcast ever,
which I'm extremely happy to debut here on Twitter at Ray Daleo.
You can say hello.
Grew up a middle class kid from long island.
He started his investment company,
Bridgewater associates out of a two bedroom apartment at age 26 now has roughly
$160 billion in assets under management.
Over 42 years he built Bridgewater into what fortune considers the fifth most
important private company in the United States.
Now along the way,
he also became one of the 100 most influential people in the world according to
time and one of the 100 wealthiest people in the world according to Forbes and
because his unique investment principles have changed industries.
Cio magazine is the one who had dubbed him the Steve Jobs of investing.
Very important.
Ray believes that his success is the result of principles he's learned codafide
and applied it to his life in business and certainly at Bridgewater,
and those principles are detailed in his new book principles,
subtitle,
life and business.
I highly,
highly recommend this book.
It has already changed how I think about making decisions in my life and in my
business.
How I think about managing how I think about communications between teams.
I could go on and on and on and it features.
Just check out the blurb from Bill Gates on the cover.
I'll give you an idea of the type of people who listen to ray very,
very closely in this interview.
We cover all sorts of ground including how ray thinks about investment
decisions,
how he thinks about correlation for instance,
and so on.
The books he would give to every graduating high school or college senior,
how he might assess something like cryptocurrencies walking through the thought
process and much,
much more we do get into backstory and how he became an investor and so on.
If you want to just jump right into a bunch of nitty gritty investing detail
which does get into the weeds,
then you can jump about 90 minutes in.
But we do cover a lot of really good stuff and many principles that apply in the
first 90 so I suggest that you listen to the whole thing,
but if you're super impatient and you want to jump around,
you can jump about 90 minutes ahead and check that out.
So I hope you enjoy this as much as I did.
And without further ado,
here is Ray Dalio.
Ray.
Thanks for coming on the show.
I'm looking forward to it.
Thank you for having me.
I have been such a follower and fan of your work and your writing and my
audience has been asking when I would reach out to you to have you on the show.
So this is,
this is a very exciting moment for me and I would love to start at the beginning
because it seems like we have some,
at least shared geographic beginnings.
Where did you grow up and how would you describe your childhood?
I grew up in new Hyde Park,
a long island and um,
I would describe my childhood as being middle class or maybe a little bit lower
middle class family.
My Dad was a jazz musician.
My mother was a stay at home mom.
I was an only child.
Were there any formative experiences you had say up until the end of college
that ended up informing your decision to become involved with investing?
Yeah,
when I was a kid I used to caddy and uh,
at the time the stock market was hot when I was 12.
I got hooked on the markets.
I bought a company that,
you know,
everybody was talking about the markets and um,
I decided I would take my caddying money and put it in the stock market.
And uh,
so I picked a stock,
the only stock I knew that was selling for less than $5 a share.
And it was kind of a stupid idea,
but I thought if I bought more shares in a way it up went up,
I'd make more money.
The company was about to go bankrupt and I'm,
somebody came along and acquired it and I tripled my money.
I was lucky and I was hooked on the stock market.
So that had a big effect that,
you know.
So from then on it drove my old addiction to the game and everything I've been
doing since related to my career.
I think that many people who are listening to this who,
no,
your name and your bio,
uh,
have the impression perhaps that every time you've stepped up at bat you've hit
home runs and it's just been an unending streak of home runs.
And I'd like to maybe humanize the experiences you've had a little bit by
talking about 1982 and I'll,
I'll,
I'll back it by reading just a,
a short excerpt from your book,
which I think paints a good picture.
It begins with,
so there I was after eight years in business with nothing to show for it,
though I had been right much more than I'd been wrong.
I was all the way back to square one.
At one point I'd lost so much money,
I couldn't afford to pay the people who worked with me one by one.
I had to let them go.
We went down to two employees,
Coleman and me.
Then Coleman had to go with tears from all his family packed up and returned to
Oklahoma.
And at that point you were down to one employee.
That's you.
And to make ends meet,
you had to borrow $4,000 from your dad until you could sell your second car.
How did that happen?
Could you describe what happened to that brought you to that point?
Let me first say that by the way,
I'm a professional mistake maker.
Uh,
it,
you know,
being in the markets or being an entrepreneur requires one to a bet against the
consensus and when one does that a fair amount of times,
you're going to be wrong.
A fair amount of times.
I've learned a lot more from my mistakes.
So I just want to let you know that anybody,
any perception that being right as part of it,
no,
the main thing is knowing what you don't know and how to deal with it.
But anyway,
what happened at the time as I analyzed the payments,
uh,
that countries,
oh banks and I calculated that those countries,
we're not going to be able to pay the U s back.
And it was a very controversial view at the time.
And as a result of that,
I took positions in the markets and I got a lot of attention because Mexico
defaulted on its debt and not many people had expected that.
And I did.
And um,
I had these positions on and I thought the stock,
my,
I thought we were going to go into a depression.
I thought the stock market was going to go through the floor.
I just didn't understand really.
And the stock market,
uh,
rose,
and this was after I had testified to Congress and I was on Wall Street Week and
then I lost the money that you referred to and you know that that's how it
happened.
Then in retrospect,
it really was the best thing that ever happened to me because it gave me the
humility that I needed to become more successful.
And that was because,
you know,
I shifted my attitude from thinking I'm right to asking myself,
how do I know I'm right?
And that opened my mind a lot.
It made me look for people who disagreed with the smartest and it also made me
manage my risks better and so on.
So that's the story
I'd look,
Dude,
dig into mistakes.
I think this will be a common thread throughout the conversation.
I have read,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
but that you're a fan of instance,
the book Einstein's mistakes,
subtitled the human failings of genius.
He was one of the greatest minds of the 20th century,
made a lot of mistakes.
You have a,
an expression is pain plus reflection equals progress.
In.
My understanding is that at Bridgewater you have,
for instance,
a lengthy assessment sessions in which employees discuss their mistakes.
What type of post mortem did you do after all that happened in 1982 or did that
come later?
The type of post game analysis that you would do on what led to that mistake?
I think for everyone,
and for me at the time when you encountered the mistake,
you experience in that pain and there's an emotional pain and that was true for
me at the time,
and then pain passes and it requires thought and making the connection of what
did I do wrong and being analytical about it,
and that was that experience and that led me to do that as a habit.
It became an increased habit.
I would literally,
every time I would make a mistake,
I would develop an instinct.
So it changed my attitude about mistakes.
I think basically they became like puzzles and if I solve the puzzle,
the puzzle being what would I do differently in the future,
I would get a gem and that Jim would be a principal that would let me do a
better job the next time.
That sort of thing came about and I wrote those principles down and refined them
over a period of time,
which is what makes up my book.
But it was that process of making enough mistakes and having painful mistakes
that led to an instinctual reaction to have reflections on what I could have
done differently that led to the progress that I'm referring to.
When I say pain plus reflection equals progress.
And I think we all learn.
I don't,
I don't think it's particularly just true of me.
I mean I think anybody who is open minded and smart knows you're going to learn
more from mistakes.
There's so much more that you can learn from mistakes because I mean mistakes
look,
I mean,
first of all they are giving you a loud signal and rewards keep you doing the
same things.
And so you don't grow from,
uh,
successes.
Successes keep you doing the same thing.
So you don't grow from successes,
mistakes,
if you can deal with them.
The right way is where the growth w plus the reflection is where the growth
comes from.
So anyway,
that's what happened.
Could you give an example from your life of a particular mistake in how you did
that analysis or reflection after the fact and what you learned from it?
Well,
I mean there are just so many mistakes.
When I was,
oh,
just,
uh,
getting out of college,
I clerked on the floor of the New York Stock Exchange and this is when the
dollar was attached to gold.
And uh,
there was a financial crisis and Richard Nixon gets on the television and says
there's no more attachment to gold.
And back then money was like checks in a checkbook that didn't have much value.
What really mattered was the fact that you could get something tangible in the
form of gold,
that you can make the conversion.
So it was a crisis who are money wouldn't be taken and other countries and so
on.
And I walked on the floor of the New York Stock Exchange Express expecting a
collapse and the stock market went through the roof.
It never happened to me before.
So that was the case.
And I went and researched currency declines in the past.
And I learned that had happened before,
but just not in my lifetime.
And one of the things that I've learned over the years is that many surprises
come because they know things that happen as surprises never happened in one's
lifetime before.
So that it's advantageous to look at beyond one's lifetime or beyond one's own
experiences to understand how the world works so that one can anticipate all of
those things and learn all the rules of how the world works.
And that's the beauty of it,
right?
And that's the excitement to learn.
You know,
how does reality work?
What are the cause effect relationships?
And then how do I deal with my realities?
So that's a case,
but I mean there are,
you know,
there are so many mistakes.
I would like to dig into the research of,
of history,
things that have happened outside of your lifetime.
Because I read that for instance,
while on one hand you have say Soros who might credit the influence of Karl
Popper,
who is one of his teachers at one point you've talked about diving very deeply
into past periods of economic upheaval,
right?
The great depression or reading daily newspapers from those eras.
Are there other practices or approaches that you've taken to examine history?
Are there any particular types of books or resources that you go into like that
to try to get a better picture of reality?
Before I deal with the particular economic history,
I'll,
I'll start off by saying I believe that basically everything is another one of
those.
In other words,
almost everything happens over and over and over again through history.
And that the key to success is to identify what one of those it is and to look
how it's worked in the many,
many,
many times.
And then to understand the cause,
effect relationships to develop one's principles for dealing with it so it can
be applied to anything.
Um,
we were talking about economics to talk about politics.
Nowadays we're hearing the term populist and populism is something that is a
bigger phenomenon that,
uh,
that we're used to in our lifetimes.
The time that populism was flourished the most was in the 1930s pretty much
leading up to World War II.
And so,
um,
I use that as an example,
I think,
okay,
where were the populists in history?
Where were those cases?
How does this thing happen?
What are the,
how does it grow?
How does it develop?
What are the usual linkages and why?
And so,
um,
that's been,
I think,
very helpful more recently and my understanding,
um,
quite a bit about what's going on,
it's affected my perspective.
So it doesn't have to be just reading history books that,
you know,
it's in anything that people have a new child and they treat it as though that's
the first time anybody's had a child.
But you gain perspective,
you can apply it,
you know,
gain that perspective of what's happened over and over.
Uh,
and it can be applied to anything if you start thinking that way.
Yeah,
it's radically beneficial.
So that way when I'm referring to that is in other words,
what is this?
What,
what one of these is it and how do those things work and what are my principles
for dealing with it?
Then life is a whole lot easier if you're not dealing with it that way.
Everything is a one off and you'll be in the middle of a blizzard of things and
you won't step above those and and deal with those instinctual principles.
For example,
you have your principles,
I really admire your stoicism.
Okay.
And I think you could rattle those principles off and you make the connection
and it's connected to your realities.
So we each have our own,
I don't want to keep it in the realm of just economics because it applies to
everything.
Definitely.
Well,
I would love to talk about problem solving,
and I'm sure principals will tie in here,
but let's just say hypothetically,
and I'm sure this is maybe a real case at,
at Bridgewater over many,
many years,
but if you have someone who's working at Bridgewater,
very,
very smart,
very ambitious,
and they've made a mistake and they are the,
they enter an assessment session,
what is the format look like and how do you help them separate symptoms of
problems from the root causes and the actual problems?
I think the first thing that I have to convey is that,
uh,
we have an idea of meritocracy.
So it's not like
somebody who's called into a room and the people like me are the bosses think
that they know the answer and that they're making an assessment of how that
person is.
And then they write down those notes.
No,
no,
no.
It's everybody's equal and having an opinion.
And by and large,
um,
if the person that's receiving,
they receive great and bad feedback,
um,
and,
and I roughy receive great and bad feedback in a night.
Nonhierarchical way.
Uh,
we approach it with the idea of how do we find out if it's true.
So it's got to be evidence based.
And then we will set up a tests.
Let's say if your,
if you get bad feedback,
we're down talking about bad feedback.
It could be for good feedback but if you,
um,
if somebody is thinking somebody's not very good at something,
they're speaking honestly.
Most importantly it's that people can be radically honest with each other and
they'll say,
um,
I don't think you're very good at that.
And they said,
I am very good at that.
And then you go through a series of tests to think it's evidenced based to try
to find out if somebody is good and bad at that.
And then you move beyond that to think,
okay,
well what can I do to get better?
Or how can I guard rail myself so that if I'm weak at something and somebody
else's strong at that thing,
we can work together.
The main thing here is to get at what people are like,
you know,
this is,
to me,
it's a weird world
that
there's a phobia about making mistakes and there's a phobia about knowing one's
weaknesses.
Mistakes are part of the process and everybody has weaknesses.
The greatest people I know have weaknesses and have become successful because
they know how to compensate for the weaknesses.
They're aware,
the stupidest people I know at least successful people I know are people who
don't own up to those weaknesses and grow.
So the exercises that we're going through or by people who choose to want to be
an a radically truthful,
a radically transparent environment and be evidence based,
but it's difficult.
It's difficult because,
um,
we're not brought up that way.
Um,
the,
it takes about 18 months to get used to it because there's the subliminal
reactions.
Now maybe this is related to the pain button APP.
I maybe not,
but could you describe the function of the pain button APP and,
and why that was created?
Yeah,
it's,
it's like I said,
pain plus reflection equals progress.
Whatever your form of pain,
the best thing to do is to record it.
So this,
the way it works is as you experience psychological pain,
you just quickly log it.
You don't analyze it at the time,
but you capture it.
What was it about or who was it with?
What happened exactly?
The nature of psychological pain is that it passes fairly quickly.
Um,
the Amygdala,
this part of the brain is the part that's the fight or flight Barb that gets
adrenaline and it reacts quickly.
And then over a period of time,
whatever the form of psychological pain it diminishes,
and that's an opportunity to reflect.
And because it's been captured in the APP,
it,
uh,
then can allow somebody to go back and reflect on that and reflect on what you
should do about it when the next one comes along.
And,
um,
is it speak to the person who caused you the pain is whatever it might be.
And you write that down and you record it.
And because it keeps in a graphic way,
a presentation,
um,
graphs,
your pains,
the different types of pains and the causes.
It gives you sort of a bio feedback that allows you to see if your actions are
reducing that pain and worthy and that might prompt you to change your actions.
Or it also shows whether you're following through on your actions.
Let's say you're having a problem with the same person doing the same thing,
causing your pain,
but you're just bottling it up.
That then if you choose to keep bottling it up,
you're not going to resolve it.
It's just going to happen over and over again.
That'll show up in the graph.
But if you do something about it and you ride it down and you can analyze it.
And so it sort of provides that kind of biofeedback that allows people to make
that progress.
And a lot of people have told me,
you know,
that it's better than a psychologist because it's there,
every day of the week.
And,
and you can see yourself,
um,
how you're,
what,
what's causing your pain,
what sorts of pains you have.
And it makes it an intellectual exercise to come up with strategies to um,
do those things that stop causing you those pains and get you what you want
for developing.
In addition to using this type of logging tool,
whether it's the APP or if someone's carrying around a small journal with them
so that they don't have misremember the details of,
of when they're triggered.
For instance.
Are there any tools that you have found helpful for people in general employees
yourself?
And one that comes to mind?
Maybe you could,
you could chat about,
and I'd love to hear about any others,
but his transcendental meditation.
And I've,
I've read for instance that you've said creativity comes from open mindedness
and centerdness seeing things in a non emotionally charged way.
Could you talk about
TM and any other tools that you have found to compliment the pain button?
So let,
let me,
let me say the tools in general,
we have developed a whole bunch of tools that it'd be fun to explain to you in
all different ways that are constantly being used.
And they were just invaluable there.
They're great.
And I,
but I want it turned my attention to transcendental meditation,
which unlike let's say,
a ADAP type tool or,
um,
some other kind of tool is a practice that I'd been doing for,
I don't know,
since 1969,
whatever that is.
Um,
anyway,
a long time.
And,
um,
uh,
I think it's worth noting that everything in our brain,
um,
every emotion we feel is physiological.
There are chemicals that go through our brains,
electronics that go through our brain and they produce these impacts.
And transcendental meditation is a practice that takes one from one's conscious
mind to go into almost a subconscious state and allows one to relax.
And,
and it's almost a blissful experience.
It relieves all stress and it brings one into the subconscious mind.
And through brain scans,
they see that the Amygdala,
which is that fight or flight part of the brain calms down.
Actually in some cases,
they conjecture that it physically changes.
And the prefrontal cortex part of the brain,
which is kind of that more thoughtful part,
uh,
lights up in is enhanced.
And so that practice not only creates,
uh,
an equanimity,
but by bringing one into the subconscious part of the brain,
it significantly enhances the creativity.
It essentially opens a passage from the subconscious to the conscious.
So that can be a reconciliation of those and F and it's really from the
subconscious where creativity comes from.
I mean,
if you think about it,
um,
one doesn't go muscle creativity like are doing a mathematical calculation or
something.
It's really like if you're ultra relaxed,
maybe you take a hot shower and these great ideas come to you or you're sleeping
and these things pop up.
They come from your subconscious part of your brain that where the intuition
that comes from.
And so by opening that passage essentially between the subconscious part of the
brain and the conscious part of the brain,
it's um,
it's wonderful.
It,
it makes one more creative.
It makes one a calmer.
It makes one almost a little bit like a Ninja in a sense that everything
with that equanimity seems to be coming at you in a more controlled centered way
so that you can react to it.
Well,
and so I've found transcendental meditation to be invaluable.
The specifics here of great interest to me for a number of reasons.
Uh,
the f the first is that I practice if a few different types of meditation,
but I did a TM session this morning for instance,
for 21 minutes because I find it takes about a minute for me just to stop
fidgeting and get settled.
But when do you typically,
do you do two sessions a day?
When do you typically do your TM?
Uh,
do you have particular location?
Any specifics,
uh,
of that practice would be very great to hear.
Uh,
because the team has come up a number of times,
uh,
and I find it very secular,
which appeals to me from people like Rick Rubin,
legendary music producer,
Chase Jarvis,
uh,
extremely accomplished photographer and CEO.
Um,
what is,
what,
what are some of the details of your practice?
Well,
I think one of the things is don't over worry about the details too much.
Just,
uh,
do it.
But the best way to do it is you do it before breakfast and you do it,
uh,
before dinner.
Having not eaten much in or not eating.
And um,
and you do it for the 20 minutes as you point out and that you do it twice a
day.
That's the,
you know,
established practice.
I basically do it,
let's say sort of two thirds of the days and I would say I probably,
maybe some days we'll do it once and not twice.
But I also always do it in addition,
whenever I have that feeling of doing it as,
as a meditator,
you probably know that you,
you can feel the difference.
So as you're going through the day,
you carry through almost an ability to shift yourself from a state of mind where
there might be a twinge of anxiety and then you can bring yourself into that
equanimity type of state.
But you also,
I also find that,
um,
there's a time where I say I need to go meditate and then I'll just meditate and
I'll meditate where I can when I can.
I mean,
I prefer,
you know,
a quiet place,
comfortable spot.
I'm not rigid about the location,
but if it was standing in my way,
my circumstances were standing in my way.
Um,
I would meditate on a plane.
Uh,
I would meditate,
you know,
we're wherever I could.
If it was a,
if it was noisy and then I was on a train,
I would still meditate.
The meditation may not be as deep,
it won't be as deep,
but it is so good.
It could be a noisy outside and I can still go from one state to another,
not the deep subconscious state,
but the state of,
let's say,
tension to relaxation.
And so that's how I'd do it.
For those people who are familiar with transcendental meditation,
it's thought of as mantra based meditation.
Since the repetition typically characterized by the repetition of a mantra or
say a one or two syllable sound that you do not say out loud,
do you sit down and immediately go into the repetition of the mantra?
Or do you take time to focus on your breath or your bodily sensations of,
before you go into the mantra,
repetition.
I take a few minutes to settle myself.
John,
just as you're describing.
Got It.
You know,
just,
yeah,
just as you're describing and it feels good at that moment and then you go into
it.
Got It.
And you mentioned before we delved into the TM,
uh,
other tools that you and the people at Bridgewater have developed.
I'd love to hear you describe any of those.
Those tools are,
I'm like,
people carry around an iPad with them.
And whenever we go into meetings,
uh,
there's a tool we call a doc collector and it's a very easy tool to allow people
to express what they think is going on and how people are doing.
And so in all meetings,
there's this data that's collected that shows what everybody's thinking while
the meeting is going on.
Now it's invaluable in many cases because you're seeing what everybody's
thinking.
So it's so different and unordinary meeting,
it's silent largely.
I mean,
there's one person speaking at a time and you don't know what the other people
are thinking.
In this particular case,
what you do was all the time,
you see how people are seeing things differently.
And so we,
we do is we take that data as it's happening and the computer does.
We have a programmed with algorithms that,
uh,
we'll look at that data and we'll then communicate back to them,
advice cause they,
this,
this computer behind.
We'll then use that to know how they think differently.
And by the way,
it's enlightening.
You would have no idea how differently people's brains are working in a meeting
or work in general.
The things they pay attention to,
the ways of the interpreted are startlingly different.
And they have the same kind of patterns to them.
And so that discovery allows people to know how they see things different and
appreciate how other people things see things different.
And then they take that,
then that allows them to know how to interact better.
So the computer through the side pad,
uh,
um,
is doing processing in the background and it will then also coach them.
In other words,
when they're dealing with somebody else or the,
um,
it will provide guidance.
It will provide feedback that's continuous.
So it's a tremendous tool,
but because you know what everybody's thinking,
it's analyzing how everybody's thinking provides that feedback and um,
gathers information across all of those people and processes it by being able to
see relationships that no one person sees.
So it's invaluable in an idea meritocracy.
We also use it for making decisions.
We do something that we call believability weighted decision making.
If you can elaborate on that,
I'd love to deaf to hear more about it.
Well,
you want to have an idea meritocracy.
If,
if you and I were partners and we had a group of people and we were partners,
how are we going to decide on the best things to do?
We're,
I think we're going to want to idea meritocracy is when the best ideas went out.
You have to have rules for doing that.
You have that procedures.
So there are three things you need to do.
The first is that you have to put your honest thoughts on the table.
A lot of people are hesitant to do that.
They keep their honest thoughts back.
But if you have a culture in which you can put your honest thoughts on the table
and everybody does,
and that's the way it operates,
now you see what people are really thinking.
Great.
That's a good first step.
Second step is you have to have thoughtful disagreement.
You have to know the art of thoughtful disagreement.
So there are processes that we go through in which,
um,
people are really hearing each other.
And as you go through that process to make better decisions than they could
individually.
And then the third thing is if disagreements remain,
you have to have idea meritocratic ways of getting past that disagreement.
You're going to do that.
If most places it's either autocratic or democratic.
Autocratic means the one with the power and makes the decision.
The boss makes the decision.
Democratic is one man,
one vote,
and it treats everybody as though they're equally valuable.
So we do what we call believability weighted decision making.
We have ways,
well,
let's just imagine what it is before we get to how we get to it.
Um,
imagine you knew each person's believability.
Who's a better decision maker at watch?
So I'll use an example.
If you had a medical condition and you went to doctors and you had a friend,
well you would know your doctors better than your friend and some doctors are
better than other doctors.
And so consciously,
um,
you're probably weighing those decisions with consideration given to their
believability.
In our place.
We have ways of determining people's believability in many different dimensions.
Maybe if it's,
uh,
a,
an accountant today would have greater believability and accounting or maybe if
it's somebody who is more creative,
we're give them,
there are more points that they actually get and they know that that person's
more creative and somebody else might be more reliable and would work well with
the person who is creative.
And so what we,
because if we didn't have this believability's according to all of those
dimensions,
when we make a decision,
we make a believability weighted decision.
We literally on the IPAD say,
would you do this?
And then everybody votes and it calculates what the vote is on a believability
weighted basis as well as um,
on an absolute basis.
And,
um,
that idea meritocracy not only produces better decision making,
but it also produces a fairness that everybody believes that the system is fair.
And that is invaluable because when you have disagreements or you even have
assessments,
um,
which people are sensitive to and you do that in a way that everybody agrees is
fair,
um,
that means that they will go along with it more that they,
the game is fair and,
um,
and,
and it's,
uh,
it works much better in getting past disagreements.
So as I said,
the third step is how do you get past the disagreements if they remain?
And we tried to do that in an idea meritocratic way through believability
weighted decision making.
What are some of the rules or guidelines that you have for preventing
disagreement from devolving into highly emotionally charged fighting in the,
in other words,
uh,
is it similar to say nonviolent communication?
Are there specific rules that you think perhaps listeners could also borrow that
you've found to be very helpful?
Uh,
for thoughtful disagreement?
You know,
there's a whole series of protocols.
For example,
there's a,
there's what we call the two minute rule.
Two minute rule means that if I say the two minute rule,
I'm allowed to speak for two minutes without an interruption,
right?
And you said the two minute rule,
you're allowed to speak for two minutes without an interruption.
There were protocols like you repeat what the person is saying,
you must repeat what the person is saying and the points they're
so that it demonstrates that you've taken in and understand what they're,
what they're saying.
And then you repeat it.
We,
uh,
allow disagreement to take place in different formats.
Um,
it might rather than being in person,
if somebody maybe is too emotional in the moment or maybe they're not good at
thinking on their feet,
uh,
we allow that disagreement to take place.
Um,
and a,
uh,
an a format that's essentially the equivalent of email exchanges.
In other words,
it written format.
Anyway,
there were a bunch of those kinds of procedures.
Uh,
we have,
we agree,
they mutually agree on who an arbiter is.
In other words,
whenever there's a disagreement,
um,
that just can't seem to get by as a standard practice.
Uh,
the protocol is to say,
uh,
let's find the person we can agree who will be a moderator and help us through
that.
And because they mutually agree on that person that then the rules of fair and
it's an easy thing to do.
So there are many of those tubs types of protocols that we use.
Um,
it's also,
um,
culturally like a big full power,
a big thing to lose your cool.
I mean,
in that way,
you know what I mean?
Culturally.
Okay.
You know,
maybe you need a,
uh,
you know,
a out.
So all of those things enter into it.
No,
those are,
those are very helpful and actionable.
And I,
I'd like to look at the dynamics of making decisions as a,
as a solo operator or close to solo operator,
just as a compliment or a contrast.
So if we flash back to when you first began,
uh,
Bridgewater associates.
So out of your two bedroom apartment at 26 years old,
do you recall any of your first big wins or things that you considered big wins
at the time?
And I'd love to just hear you describe what went into what made those big win.
In other words,
the thinking behind it.
You know,
the,
the funny thing is,
um,
I can hardly ever remember my big wins.
I do remember my big losses.
We can talk,
we can talk about those too.
Yeah.
It's so,
it's so funny because,
you know,
I look at it and I said,
well,
I,
I guess I must have had a bunch of wins or successes because of,
you know,
uh,
how things have went,
you know,
the business is good and done well and all of that.
But like I think of my history
and I really think of those mistakes and I think that's so great because it
shows that that's a much better learning tool.
But,
uh,
okay,
so my big wins.
You don't know I think about that.
Uh,
that time I think,
no,
the things I remember where the,
where the fun things,
but a guy,
you know,
guys I played rugby with and parties and,
um,
and those kinds of things.
I don't remember a particularly big winning well.
I do remember some things,
you know,
I remember one time,
um,
when we got the Kodak Account
Again,
I was,
uh,
in a position,
it's okay,
here's a guy and he's analyzing the markets and then he has this small team of
people that he's analyzing the markets.
And so I didn't have a long track record and I didn't have a institution.
And,
uh,
you know,
sort of competing with the big institutions of the world,
the JP Morgans and everybody.
And,
uh,
and by the way,
we'd beat them well anyway,
um,
which shows that the individuals,
the powers within the individual.
But anyway,
I remember when we got the Kodak Account,
um,
because at the time Kodak was,
uh,
you know,
a big important client and them giving us that account,
uh,
was a big deal for us because it was kind of a stamp of institutional,
um,
approval.
And it was all I remember,
you know,
the money mattered too because we would know that we were a bit more financially
secure.
So I remember that as a big win and I remember it so terrifically because we
were asked to submit,
um,
research inflammation and we were just a small team of people and you know,
we stayed up all night and with,
you know,
pizza and beer and all of that and um,
I remember it so sweetly because it was the dream of making our miracle happen
and we,
and the pulling together,
that's the meaningful relationships part.
I believe that I want meaningful work and meaningful relationships.
And so that was what that was about.
And we got the account and we won and that was,
yeah,
that was a big deal.
Why did you guys win?
I think it's a combination of,
of being totally
unconventional and having better processes and then there's a hell of a lot of
determination.
I think three things make up the successful life by and large.
First you have to have audacious goals,
big dreams.
Then when you are headed toward those goals,
you're going to have problems going to deal with reality.
You have to deal with those problems in that reality.
Realistic League,
learning from mistakes,
writing down those principles and the likes.
So that's the second part.
Dealing with reality in a practical way where you learn about mistakes.
And then the third is determination.
Because if you're going for your goals and you're encountering your mistakes and
you're learning and you do that with determination,
you're going to get better all the time.
You're going,
you can't help but get better and you do that a long enough amount of time and
you're going to far exceed your dreams.
Nice success as far succeeded,
what I ever imagined in a one bit at a time.
And it's just that process.
If you were to conversely look at intelligent people who are unhappy,
what do you think the primary causes of that unhappiness are?
I think it goes back to this notion of meaningful work and meaningful
relationships.
Uh,
intelligence and happiness probably have no correlation with each other in
studies,
the repeatedly been shown and money is very little correlated with happiness.
The highest correlation with happiness is community.
Am I part of a community?
Do I feel connections with other people that's been,
you know,
literally genetically programmed into us from it's estimated between 1,000,002
million years ago before it was we were even mankind.
So that sense of meaningful relationships I think is very,
very important.
And if you have meaningful work,
like you're on a mission and you have meaningful relationships and I think it's
almost impossible not to be happy.
I mean,
there'll be unhappy moments in your life that you encounter this thing or that,
but,
uh,
the people who are unhappy seem to be missing those things.
I think this,
you know,
this might be a good place to give listeners a little bit of background that
they probably don't have,
which is a,
a conversation you and I had that I really appreciated when I was very nervous
at head not too long ago doing a rehearsal of my talk,
a which explored some of my experiences with manic depression and even a close
call with [inaudible] near suicide in college.
And you're very kind,
you came up and spoke to me after I came offstage and I was,
I was hoping perhaps you could talk about some of what you shared with me and,
uh,
perhaps,
your son's experience in what he's found helpful
in mitigating some of these darker or harder moments that he's also had.
Sure.
I'd be happy to.
I should stay say that when I described unhappiness and answer to your prior
question before I was not dealing with what also was clinical depression,
um,
which is also a different thing.
That's,
that's,
uh,
it is a,
it is a chemical reaction I'm having to do with Serotonin,
dopamine coming in,
sports and sputters and so on.
There's a physiological element that,
um,
is driving it.
And it's,
uh,
so that's,
that's a big thing.
So my son,
when he was,
uh,
I think about 27 filmmaker,
very creative,
was,
um,
in his new job in Los Angeles.
Um,
very excited,
stayed up all night,
smoke marijuana,
partied all night,
very energetic and,
and,
and basically,
um,
when crazy,
he,
uh,
at the hotel,
he took the computer that was at the reception and smashed it.
He was,
he went into the,
uh,
the police came.
Um,
he was rebellious.
They'd beat him up and so on and so forth.
And we then began our journey,
um,
through,
uh,
three years of his bipolar episodes.
And that was,
um,
you know,
an incredibly difficult and eye opening and in retrospect,
wonderful experience.
Some of the most painful experiences in retrospect give you the appreciations
that you wouldn't otherwise have.
Um,
and that was,
that was that experience.
And so,
ask your questions pertaining to it.
I'd be happy to tell you.
He made the,
the quick answer to this by the way,
is he did all the,
he did things right eventually that Julie did a lot of wrong things in between,
but they came out of that three year period and then he became a successful film
maker.
His movie,
the first movie made was called touch with fire,
which was love story with Katie Holmes on bipolar and he has through that movie
in his speeches and so on,
we know saved a number of lives and also help to really destigmatize that
because those with bipolar are often very creative people.
I learned that,
you know,
a genius,
creative genius is at the edge of insanity.
Anyway.
Um,
what,
what questions do you have about that experience?
I'd love hear
what I,
what your son has found to be helpful in terms of tools or resources,
approaches,
routines,
anything that has,
that has,
that he has found too,
uh,
help them better navigate and manage everything that is part of his makeup.
I suppose.
Much like it is part of my makeup.
Sure.
There's these really for protocols and um,
I gave him a Saint Christopher medal and on the back I put the initials of those
four protocols so that he would keep it close to him.
And um,
so I know them well.
First of all,
the first one is w we have t,
t,
m,
those are the initials and we and that represented take medicine.
And by the way,
the amount of medicine that he's taken has,
uh,
because of his improvements and so on has diminished,
quite a lot but take medicine and it also represented TM,
transcendental meditation.
So do the trend transcendental meditation and take the medicine,
no drugs or substance abuse non be clean,
go to bed,
never too late.
It's not a matter of just have eight hours sleep.
It's,
we have our rhythms and that basically go to bed by 11 and maybe once a week you
could be up till one o'clock in the morning and then what we call monitoring.
Now monitoring is much less important to him now,
but at the time is being open about his bipolar and having people around them
know and actually sort of monitoring his behavior so that they could raise a red
flag,
um,
and help them deal with that if he was going in one way or another.
Uh,
that,
that those were the things that were very helpful in addition,
have to be very careful about changing time zones.
So if you're flying to Europe or far away,
you have to do that in a way that you pace it so that it doesn't get triggered.
And as I said,
he went through this,
you would never,
he's one now,
one of the most centered people I know,
happily married given us two grand kids,
you know,
it's just been a miracle and I really do believe it's that combination and,
and he's learned and shown other people that that combination can work for
anybody.
That's extremely helpful and I think valuable for a lot of people listening.
And I want to reiterate something that you mentioned because I only realized it
in the last maybe two years and that is the going to bed earlier,
I've always been very,
very nocturnal and a a night owl and particularly say on book deadlines and so
on going to bed at four or five,
six in the morning,
waking up very late.
And that is,
that has historically absolutely been correlated with a much,
a much more severe and extended downtimes.
Uh,
so I do just want to uh,
reiterate what you said,
which is that going to bed by say 11 o'clock,
uh,
it has for me at least been extremely helpful in,
in mitigating a lot of what we're talking about.
By the way,
it is so great that he is open and you are open and you can communicate it
because I found out,
uh,
do you know that um,
24% of the population in one form or another has been diagnosed with some form
of mental illness of some form of challenge that,
because you know,
the brain is like a,
an Oregon,
it is an organ and it has those things.
And some of the most creative people,
uh,
you would know,
you know,
that,
um,
Abraham Lincoln and Winston Churchill and Tchaikovsky and I'm on that,
the list goes on and on of unbelievably great,
brilliant creative people,
uh,
simultaneously on the challenge by this and by making people aware,
um,
and um,
in one dimension or another,
either whether they're dealing with somebody who has such a challenge or to de
stigmatize it and realize like,
I look at you what a role model you are.
And by being open about that particular challenge,
people can really appreciate that we have a number of bipolar people who work
here and we,
and when you know how to deal with it and there were,
you know,
tremendous advantages to it too because it's a,
it's a way of thinking.
I mean there was these mood ships,
but there is also,
um,
an unbelievably high percentage of those people are creative.
So in certain professions and so on.
But anyway,
I just want to compliment you or express my appreciation for you.
I'm having this conversation and,
and being so open with it and it's,
I'm sure you would say as my son would,
it's very helpful because when everybody around you understands it,
it's helpful to you too.
It is helpful and I really appreciate the kind words ray and I should also
mention that for decades I kept this secret and close to the chest and I was
very ashamed of,
uh,
just the,
the nature of how my physiology worked ultimately and I so fearful about talking
about a lot of this publicly in even the Ted talk was a,
I had a very separate,
very different tedtalk that I scrapped a few weeks beforehand because I felt
morally obligated to talk about this more publicly.
And in doing so felt quite the opposite of what I feared.
It was actually an enormous burden and weight lifted off of my shoulders.
And it's,
it's really been liberating to talk more freely about it.
I understand that completely because that's what,
that's what my son does.
I mean,
that's my son's reaction.
If you want to talk about it in a,
you know,
in a more serious way.
I'm quite an expert on the whole thing,
the best doctors.
And you know,
I,
I really believed that I could probably be of some help if you feel that it's
not entirely under control.
Thank you.
No,
I,
I appreciate it.
And it,
it's a to segue a bit here,
so absolutely appreciate the offer and that's,
that's something I'll remember.
You seem like a very astute cultivator of talent and what I'd,
I'd love to know is if there were any particular mentors of your own who uh,
okay.
You could describe or share with us that could be very early on,
it could be in your investing career,
but any,
any mentors who come to mind and what,
what they taught you or helped to cultivate in you?
I remembered nice kind people,
not a mentor.
I,
I couldn't go to a mentor,
but I remember,
um,
somebody who a,
when I was caddying and he was clerking on the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange,
um,
a very successful Wall Street guy.
And I used to caddy for him and we would talk about markets and he gave me,
um,
not only advice,
but there was the kindness and the caring and the direction that was helpful.
I'd,
I don't know that he was an ongoing mentor,
but he was a role model in many ways and did provide guidance.
So maybe I think maybe he was,
but not an ongoing mentor.
Um,
I remember teachers,
you know,
that,
uh,
you know,
serve that role.
But not much.
Most of my learning has been from mistakes.
I have a terrible rote memory,
by the way.
I mean a terrible anything that doesn't have a reason for being what it is.
I practically can't remember.
I can't remember phone numbers,
names,
anything along those lines.
So I tend to learn.
I'm not by being taught or going to my memory,
I learn through my experiences and,
uh,
and my kind of more subliminal learning.
Let's see.
It seems also that you're well read,
uh,
and I,
I'd love to actually just go back for a second to Einstein's mistakes when you
pick up a book like that.
Two questions.
Number one,
how did you choose that book or find it?
And number two is how do you read,
what is your reading process?
The book was given to me because people know that I,
I liked that stuff.
And,
uh,
the way I read,
um,
it depends on what I'm reading,
but I will kind of skim and it depends on how much time and know and a lot of
things.
But generally speaking on,
I'll try to go through a book pretty quickly by being able to sort out what the
main ideas are from the degression.
So is this kind of a little bit of a strategy,
you know,
how like they'll tell you the story and the story and the story might go on for
awhile and then it then gets to the point they're trying to make.
So I'm my,
when I'm going through the stories on Michael Quicker,
um,
I might be scanning for the,
you know,
top of the paragraph to get an idea of what they're doing,
doing and then go into the section that I'm,
I'm most interested.
I mean,
I would say I would be typically a reading that way unless it is something in
which,
you know,
there's uh,
not that sort of a book that there's either something where on enjoying the,
the flavor of the wording and the,
you know,
the sentence structure and the beauty or the,
the,
the thoughtfulness and that I really want to take that in and I don't want to
scan,
it'll vary.
I like to get the most out of each book as quickly as I can because the number
that I'm trying to go through,
um,
you know,
is comparatively large.
So I've got a pile of books or you're sitting in front of me and you know,
they torment me because they tapped.
I'm very curious.
I would say curiosity
is a big motivator from mine.
So you know,
the world has got much too much to offer relative to my capacity to digest it.
What are the books that you currently have in front of you or that are sitting,
sitting there like undone homework assignments?
What do you,
what did,
what do you currently have on the,
on the roster or potential roster?
I have sapiens,
I have the Greek hero,
Michael Lewis is the undoing project,
the upside of inequality,
the Serengeti rules,
uh,
from bacteria to Bach and back,
which is about the evolution of the mind,
a magic web,
a whole pile over there.
This is fantastic.
I do mostly original research.
So in,
in addition to,
I mean,
looking through books and,
and through it,
um,
like I really liked to get into,
you know,
the data.
I mean I'm,
I'm a researcher basically.
Is there anything that you're researching right now or that you've researched
recently?
The bottom 60% of the population and what the world and life and the economy is
like for them because they're,
there are two different economies in the world.
The average is a very,
very misleading.
The top two tenths of 1% of the population as a net worth,
which is about equal to the bottom,
90% combined.
And um,
so,
um,
uh,
researching more about what that's like and it's,
it's quite a,
it's quite a bleak,
difficult picture.
So that's the thing I'm researching right now.
What drove you to,
to research that?
Is it just to understand the,
the implications and secondary and tertiary implications of that?
Or is,
was there something driving that?
I think,
I think right now we're in the midst of an era that's very much like the 30s
that is,
um,
uh,
in which this wealth and opportunity gap and the populism that is being,
um,
that's coming from it.
And the divisions which are great,
I mean large,
um,
is a,
is a defining moment of our time and this exists around the world.
If economies where to go down now,
I do believe that there would be a great deal of conflict and I think that we're
seeing the conflict play out politically.
Uh,
uh,
not only in the United States,
but you're seeing it in different places or interactions.
I think it's the,
um,
it's the defining issue of maybe that's overreaching,
but it is certainly one of the most important issues of our time.
And I mean this year,
next year,
the year following,
because that's the basis at which,
um,
are we going to have conflict or where one side is fighting the other side.
This is a matter of principles we're talking about principles again are the
principles that hold us together as Americans greater than those that divide us.
How are we going to,
how we want to be with each other.
So this is this,
this understanding and,
and,
uh,
all of these perspectives I think is,
is,
is very important at the time.
So I've been definitely going to come back to a related thread on that.
But before I get there,
I wanted to ask you of of the books that you mentioned that you were not gifted,
how did you,
or why did you choose any of them?
Like the Greek hero,
the undoing project sapiens from bacteria to Bach and back,
any of those,
why did you choose them?
I would suppose that the,
each one has to,
is,
is different because of the themes of interest.
I'm fascinated by evolution.
I think evolution is the greatest force in the universe and everything.
And the purpose of everything is to evolve.
We as individuals are just vessels for our DNA is evolving.
So I'm,
uh,
I'm,
I'm fascinated in evolution.
I'm fascinated in how the brain works.
The Greek heroes,
very,
very interested in,
in terms of,
um,
uh,
one of the greatest books,
is Joseph Campbell's hero over a thousand faces,
which,
um,
takes the character of,
you know,
going through life and what are the attributes that different people have.
So difference in values.
Um,
so there it's an eclectic group of interests.
I'm interested in nature a lot.
Um,
so I tend to,
I'm also particularly interested in the ocean,
so I will read about nature and the ocean.
Uh,
and these are just curiosities,
but then they become themes.
I guess I'm not interested in cooking.
I'm not interested in like a whole bunch of things,
but so they are,
they do come in these categories.
Are there any particular books that you could mention?
And don't worry,
I won't Belabor the book stuff forever,
but,
uh,
any books you mentioned Joseph Campbell,
that have had a strong impact on your life or your thinking and maybe a way to
frame that would be if you were a,
and certainly,
uh,
one of the books in answer to the question that I'm about to pose could be your
own certainly.
Um,
but if you were to give,
say every graduating senior in college or high school,
a handful of books,
what might you give them?
Ah,
the books I'd give them would be lessons from history.
This is the Durant's.
They were the,
um,
the great,
maybe the greatest historians of all time.
Anyway,
we're over 5,000 years of history,
probably road 5,000 pages on it.
And they took this book,
I think it's 104 pages,
and they took the themes of history.
It could be from religion,
natural resources,
who knows,
uh,
each one of these things.
And they looked at it for themes of history through history.
I think that that would be great.
A river from Eden by Dawkins,
Richard Dawkins on another very short book on evolution.
It just really puts things in perspective.
Um,
again,
I would say Joseph Campbell's hero's a thousand faces.
Uh,
those would be the three books that I would say that would be the combination.
And the beauty of,
you know,
particularly two of those books is it's not going to take loan to,
to read them.
Hero of a thousand faces a little bit dense,
but it's so rich.
So it's,
uh,
it's,
it's a good one.
Why is it those are,
I need to get on a combine this as soon as we get off the,
uh,
the phone,
but I,
why is it,
and maybe this isn't true across the board,
but whether it's in early stage startups or in the realm of,
say,
broadly speaking,
hedge funds or eight structures or asset management,
the best investors that I've met almost all have a fascination with evolution.
Why is that?
Don't have a clue.
Okay.
All right.
Then we don't have to,
we don't have to dwell on it.
Uh,
for whatever reason.
Yeah.
It seems to be a pattern.
Uh,
there their few maxims I'd like to ask you about.
And uh,
if these are misquotes please correct me.
The first is ask yourself whether you have earned the right to have an opinion.
Can you elaborate on that?
I mean,
yeah.
I mean
all you want is the right answer,
right?
And there's such a bias to think that just because you have an opinion that it's
valuable or the 30s,
so stuck with it.
I mean,
that's really stupid,
right?
I mean,
it's like in everything.
You just want the right opinion wherever it's going to come from.
So if you gain humility,
I believe that one of the greatest tragedies of mankind,
individuals is to hold wrong opinions in their head that so easily could be
stress tested to find out if they're right or wrong.
If you,
if you can sort of give that up and think,
how do I know I'm right,
you're going to significantly raise the best,
raise your probabilities and making better decisions.
I mean,
that's the,
that's the big thing.
They're only two things you need to do in life in order to be successful.
You first,
you need to know what the best decisions are.
And second,
you have to have the courage to make them to do what's necessary.
And on the first,
the greatest problem is that people just look inside their heads with,
for their opinions where they can really get rid of the bad ones,
take the best that they can get elsewhere.
And by doing that,
by exploring different people's views,
not just their conclusions,
but the reasoning behind their conclusions,
they can learn such a tremendous amount.
We talk about books.
Well,
the conversations are much better than books.
So you can have those conversations and learn when people have differences and
just pick the best opinions.
Right.
Isn't that sensible?
Yeah,
no,
it's definitely sensible.
How do you,
uh,
what are some good questions that someone can ask to explore someone's reasoning
behind their conclusions?
Except I think that I'm doing,
it's so easy for people to become charged.
Uh,
are there any good questions for those people who,
uh,
the vast majority are not going to operate within Saint Bridgewater associates?
Uh,
what are,
what are some good ways to explorer normally investigate someone else's
reasoning behind their conclusions?
Well,
I think the real driver of it is when there's a difference of opinions to,
do you have a real curiosity to understand why.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's really through the,
um,
you know,
okay.
The fear of being wrong,
combined with the curiosity of wondering why somebody would have another opinion
and,
and that becomes the motivator.
And so,
you know,
you kind of ask why and you think,
does that make sense?
And then come back with other questions.
Uh,
so it's,
I would say,
I think most people,
um,
are,
you know,
too often they start with opinion.
There's psychological tests that show that people start with an opinion and
filter information that comes to them to be consistent with their opinion.
Right?
Yeah.
Well then you're not living in reality.
You're living in a sort of illusion of confirmation bias.
Right?
Right.
And it's,
it's so,
besides being so damaging,
it's so much less enriching.
So this I think is a related in a sense to,
uh,
maybe another maxim that,
I'd love for you to elaborate on,
which is don't pick your battles,
fight them all.
What does that mean?
That's one of the most misunderstood.
So I'm glad you asked him about it because it's clear that many things are
symptomatic.
A little things are symptomatic of a bigger things.
So under that principle it explains like,
um,
if somebody is behaving in a certain way and you think,
well,
that's not a big thing,
but you don't
why somebody would do that,
it may be symptomatic of a bigger thing.
So when you start to almost,
I might say,
pull every thread,
as you start to pull the threads,
you start to see the connections because you're chilling to get at what's
everything symptomatic of.
So that's what you're really trying to get a,
is it,
is that,
what is the person,
like,
what does that situation like?
Why would it manifest itself that way?
So,
um,
uh,
it's a,
it's a probably a principal that I,
you know,
throws people off and I probably have an articulated very well.
What are some of the biggest challenges that you've had within Bridgewater at,
at different phases of its development?
I mean,
are there,
are there any,
were there any particular sort of forks in the road that are memorable to you,
where you had to improve or fix something?
I,
I'd like to start with the overarching challenge that is a constant challenge
and then we can go back to some of the actual,
you know,
various forks in the road.
The overarching challenge is people's two thems.
In other words,
think about it in this,
this way,
there are two use inside you.
There is the thoughtful you prefrontal cortex type of,
you know,
thoughtful you.
And then there's the subliminal emotional you and you're not aware actually of
the subliminal emotional you.
That's why it was Freud's great this,
the governor in that there's the subliminal that's really controlling you but
you're not in your consciousness.
And there were those to use and they're often at odds.
The example,
the classic example would be of course something where you did something that
you didn't want to do.
He ate the cake that you didn't want to eat,
but in any way where you punched somebody or something.
And so there are these two use that are in a battle for each other.
And so what we've observed on a constant basis is that in addition to having,
uh,
disagreements between people,
we see that that emotional,
subliminal them often can be in control of their more thoughtful them.
And that those are ongoing battles.
And that's basically the battle.
That's the battle that almost everybody all the time is doing well.
So imagine how confusing it is.
You know,
you have to use within you that are battling with each other and then somebody
else you're dealing with as to within them.
And so it can get,
uh,
you know,
you get kids difficult,
every,
yeah,
every conversation has at least four people in.
Yeah.
So that's it.
And if you can,
if you could know how to deal with that,
that's a constant struggle.
So the thing that we find is that a very,
very,
very few people have a problem intellectually liking what's going on here.
Um,
it's fair.
It's honest.
There's no politics.
It's anybody can,
um,
in an idea meritocratic way.
You can argue their case.
There isn't,
it's not hierarchical.
It's fantastic.
And all of those ways,
the challenges that they have or then with their emotional,
you reconciling with their intellectual you.
And that's an ongoing challenge.
Um,
uh,
you know,
that's uh,
all the,
all the time.
So that's a,
that's a theme I would say is a constant thing.
Okay,
well then,
you know,
twists and turns at every phase in life you have,
you have different,
uh,
challenges.
I mean,
you know,
not having any money,
any resources,
and then having to do things from,
from myself.
You know,
you're an entrepreneur,
no,
no money,
no resources.
And then having to do,
sit by the computer,
rent the place,
do all of that was a one kind of challenge.
And you know,
then you have the small team and you have those dreams and you work with them
and it's fantastic.
But you didn't have enough resources and then you grow and you have the exact
opposite things happening to you and they produce their own challenges.
And you know,
you have too many people and you don't get to know each other as well as you did
before,
but you have plenty of resources.
But you might have the,
um,
you know,
the challenge of how do you maintain that quality relationship with that larger
group of people.
Then one has to figure out how you main connect.
We have 1500 people that work at Bridgewater.
Um,
how does that connectivity,
that same kind of excitement,
admission and togetherness that happened when we had five or 50,
how is,
how is that maintained?
And that's a new strategy.
So you always,
one always has these different problems and the various inflection points that
lead one of the forks in the road that are the points that you're referring to.
Um,
and they're the junctures your referring to,
you're referring to.
So,
I mean,
they're just so,
so many of them.
But I'd love to maybe dig into is a word that gets,
gets used a lot.
And I'd love to hear how you define and think about risk,
uh,
specifically.
And I have a quote here,
uh,
that,
that maybe we could use as a jumping off point.
And I'm not sure exactly where it's from,
but risky things are not in themselves risky if you understand them and control
them.
If you do it randomly and you're sloppy about it,
it can be very risky.
And then it goes on their words,
not yours.
The key to success,
their words is quote,
a figuring out where is the edge and how do I stay the right distance from the
edge.
How do you think about risk?
Because that's a word that a lot of people throw around.
A,
I have a feeling that,
that you think about it maybe in more specific terms or more clearly than a lot
of folks had.
How do you think about or define risk?
Well,
I think the most important thing is there's,
there's the risk of the ruined risk of being knocked out of the game,
risk of the unacceptable.
And then there's a risk of,
um,
the painful mistake and they're a world of difference.
Um,
like I have to know how not to die,
how not,
how to get knocked out of the game.
That's an important risk.
So thinking about all the different ways that that can happen and making sure
all of those ways are covered is,
is number one.
And then there's the other kind of risk which is take it,
have the experiences.
Um,
I guess maybe the example would be if I was saying skiing comes to mind know,
you know,
don't kill yourself,
but if you're not falling a lot and hurting yourself a lot,
you're probably not learning.
So to distinguish between,
um,
when you say risk averse,
uh,
be very risk prone in terms of being able to have the experiences that are the
learning risky experiences that even produce some of the pains that allow the
learning but you know,
don't get knocked out of the game.
And then I think of risk as,
you know,
how do you do that?
How do I improve my return to risk ratio?
And I know that the most important way that you can do that,
there's a few ways,
but one of the most important ways is,
uh,
knowing how to diversify one's bets without reducing one's returns.
There are a bunch of things that are equally good and you know how to,
um,
take all those equally good things but they're not correlated,
would mean that I could do a much better job.
Just to give you an idea,
think,
think of something as being correlated.
Like something like some,
uh,
bet something.
There's a way we think of that as correlation,
but you can almost think of it as,
you know,
a different kind of bed.
If it is 60% correlated and,
and you start with a particular level of risk and you add in the second and
third and fourth and fifth and a thousand different items to diverse,
you're by yourself.
You will only reduce your risk by about 15%,
maybe a little bit more than 15%.
If they're correlated.
If you do that with uncorrelated things,
uncorrelated bets,
um,
you at 15 on correlated batch,
you will reduce your risk by over 80% so now the holy grail of investing,
the thing that I learned,
and that's the most important,
is that if I can have 10 or 15,
ideally 15 but even if it's five good uncorrelated bets,
okay,
that's,
that's the holy grail.
So the holy grail is 15 good uncorrelated bets because it will,
if they're all equally good and expected return,
in other words,
let's say they were all going to have an expected return of 10% by way of
example,
then on average you would do,
you won't lower your expected return because they're all on average about 10%
but in terms of the risk,
you will eliminate 80% of the risk.
So you improve your return to risk ratio by a factor of five.
So what I'm saying is that knowing the value of uncorrelated bets,
um,
is incredibly important.
So when you're thinking about it as a business,
I think about it as a mason,
basically a betting strategy and every one of the bets that I make,
but if you're thinking about,
let's say your business is,
if you can create a good but uncorrelated things,
that power of diversification is so much more valuable than trying to make any
one bet much greater.
So I think about diversification and I also think that in terms of,
uh,
let's say batch or raising my probability of being right,
one of the most important ways of raising my probability of being right is not
being confident that I'm writing and being able to go out there and,
and gather the triangulation.
So something for me is it technique is a quality,
uh,
triangulation.
Basically,
you know,
if I can find three people don't know,
let's say it's a medical condition,
but it could be any decision if I could find three people who are excellent
experts who will disagree with each other because they're committed to the right
answer and I can get triangulation and also listen to their disagreements.
Um,
I'm significantly raising my probabilities of,
uh,
of being right.
So there,
you know,
techniques like that,
uh,
humility and triangulation of,
of great people,
um,
is an excellent way of raising one's probability of making a good decision.
I'd lifted
to unpeel the layers a little bit on uncorrelated bets.
So what I'm wondering is it's,
I think about this just say in my own life,
uh,
with various types of investing and I'm by no means,
anyone with a track record like yours.
But,
uh,
how the,
the question that comes to mind for me is,
or observation rather,
and I'd love for you to smash it to pieces if it's not accurate,
but that
with a limited Dataset,
you can,
if you're able to crunch some numbers,
identify,
say things that go up at the same time or down at the same time.
So the correlation or that are inversely correlated.
So when [inaudible] goes up,
B tends to go down.
At what point do you consider yourself confident something is uncorrelated
because it seems like you'd need a much larger dataset to conclude confidently
that something is uncorrelated?
Well,
the,
I think there are two ways of determining the correlation,
uh,
that they're uncorrelated and that is,
are they in
you referred to the first,
but I think it's the worst,
but still has value,
which is how did they move together in the past?
I think the more important is to understand like,
are they intrinsically different things?
So
if you were going to say,
I'm going to involve,
um,
invest in this silicon valley startup and timber in Colorado or something,
right?
You know,
that those are intrinsically different things.
So,
and,
and I think you can,
um,
get a good sense of that,
uh,
by,
you know,
just even knowing what they are.
So you'll know that that particular startup will have a particular thing that
will make it successful.
I don't know what we can imagine.
It might be,
but it might be having nothing to do with something else.
So now I think of what are the fundamental determinants of the price movement?
And you don't have to get so precise about it.
I to think it through probably,
uh,
maybe,
an overly analytical way,
but,
um,
knowing that they're intrinsically different as good enough.
And then,
and then now back to your question of,
um,
the data set,
it then becomes a,
um,
I'm going to give you more complex answer than you probably want,
but
let's do it.
Okay.
So,
um,
it has to,
it,
it has to do with,
um,
a combination of a sample size and environmentally by it dip biases,
differences,
in other words.
Um,
first
how,
how much sample sized you have and is that over many years or did they have
something in common that would affect them?
So if I have many years and a large number of samples in that number of years,
I can have a higher level of reliability.
If I'm just looking at the numbers then if I had a short term period because
correlations will change.
Right?
So because it,
so is it a number of years and is it in a different environment?
I have a rule and in terms of most of my decision making is it,
it has to be timeless and universal.
So timeless means if I take a period of time where the correlations or that,
which I'm discovering true in all of those periods of time.
So I like to go back a long time,
but let's say you have a limited amount of data that's a handicap.
The more data you have,
the better.
But still,
if I change the periods,
um,
in this year,
did that correlation,
was it the same as the correlation in the prior year and was the correlation the
same in the year before that the correlation,
let's say,
of daily returns or you have correlation,
a minute returns.
So,
Eh,
so timeless and as far back as you go.
And I like to deal with universal.
What I mean by universal,
okay.
Um,
is that if,
if I have a decision rule or equities or bonds or an asset class or something
and I see its behavior,
did it behave the same in uh,
with the same drivers in another country and another country?
So we're the correlations for example,
between stocks and bonds in Spain,
similar to the correlations between stocks and bonds in Brazil,
similar to this correlation stocks and bonds in the United States.
Okay.
That'll give you more of a sense that the correlation between stocks and bonds
is x.
Then if you have,
um,
just it happening in one place.
So timeless and universal or just for most decisions are,
uh,
rules that I,
I look at,
but at the end of the day I get really more comfort by being able to understand
the intrinsic determinants.
So if I'm talking about investments,
um,
cause that's the subject we can talk about a lot of other things.
But anyway,
if I'm talking about correlations of investments,
every investment is a lump sum cash payment.
Now for an income stream in the future,
uh,
if I buy a bond,
I give a lump sum payment and they're going to give me so much per month all the
way for whatever the length of the bond is,
the majority of the 20 years or whatever that is.
If I'm having a stock,
it's a lump sum payment.
And then we estimate what are the future cash flows.
So this is uncertainty about those cash flows but that,
but you will look at those cashflows,
they will all be affected by the discount rate,
the interest rate we use to calculate the present value.
So there will be an intrinsic reason that they will be correlated and there will
be intrinsic reasons that they that drive their correlation.
Let's say if I'm getting too technical,
please excuse me,
but all of those investments are going to have the interest rate that we're
using to calculate the present value in common and therefore that will drive a
correlation between that while the items that affect their cash flows could be
different and that will drive then something that one can analyze and see that
there are correlations would be different from that attribute.
If you break investments down and you look at what the causality is,
it's you know it's better than if you're just looking at past numbers.
But you could look at it either of those two ways.
Ideally both
for those people who,
who would like to get a better understanding of the,
some of the underlying factors that affect the,
the economic engine,
so to speak,
interest rate,
et Cetera,
what would your recommendation be if they wanted to educate themselves?
I did a 30 minute video called how the economic machine works in which
everything that I know that most value describes it,
30 minutes,
it's on youtube.
I'd recommend that they go there in 30 minutes.
They'll have most of what I think is valuable and how,
and,
and understanding how it works.
Perfect.
It's a pretty simple machine.
It's like almost anything if you,
if you think about it,
most of the important things that are driving almost anything can be described
pretty simply.
So that's what I attempted to do in that video on youtube.
It's,
um,
it's been downloaded 5 million times and I mean,
people,
it's rated highly.
So I think it,
I think it's helpful
and I will tell everybody listening.
I'll link to that in the show notes as well so people can easily access that.
Uh,
just to pose a hypothetical because I'd love to hear how you approach it.
Not necessarily if it's a long or short decision,
although it could be,
but just to hear how you would even go about assessing a potential opportunity
because for instance,
I'm very primitive compared to,
uh,
how your operation and how you would approach investing.
But living in Silicon Valley for instance,
uh,
as long as I have,
17 years now,
I have informational advantage when it comes to choosing and assessing different
startup opportunities and,
uh,
elsewhere people might have a say,
an analytical or behavioral advantage or fill in the blank.
If,
if you were to look at,
for instance,
cryptocurrency,
bitcoin,
all this other stuff,
how would you even begin to assess that and whether it poses a good or bad
opportunity for investment?
Well,
everything I look at is I tried to look at who are the buyers and sellers and
what are they,
what motivates them and what are they going to do?
[inaudible]
so I break it down.
I,
I analyze,
uh,
now I would know,
I don't know,
uh,
how are we do that a bit coin and I don't know that it would apply to
everything,
but as a general theme,
if you know who the buyers and sellers are and what their motivations are,
um,
how big they are and so on,
you can,
you know,
you can pretty much calculate,
you can go a long way to understanding what the price is likely to do in the
future.
That's very different from something like value investing,
which is something that's is,
you know,
my lump sum payment today is this and the future cash flows over the next number
of years will be this.
So I'm,
I'm very much a much more driven to the,
um,
the buying and selling.
Um,
in terms of something like a cryptocurrency,
uh,
first of all,
I'm not an expert on,
on the cryptocurrencies.
I would think what I'm describing is super important to get at because there
were two purposes of occurrancy.
Any currency is a medium of exchange or a store hold of wealth.
When we think of dollars and you will use it as a medium of exchange or if we're
holding it as a bond,
it's a payment over a period of time and that's it's a store hold of wealth.
In the case of cryptocurrencies right now it's not a very practical medium of
exchange yet.
Uh,
I mean it,
you know,
I have,
I been coins and I tried to go spend them in.
It's not easy to go spend them.
Uh,
and then when we think of it as,
um,
a store hold of wealth,
no,
today it's primarily a speculative market.
So it's somebody knowing that it's not,
it's intrinsic value that you're going to be looking at.
It's really thinking about who are the buyers,
who are the sellers and what they are likely to do and projecting that that's
going to be the driver of investing in a cryptocurrency.
Could you talk a little bit more about assessing the motivations of buyers and
sellers and you could do with any asset class or any kind of hypothetical but
specific example.
Because I guess in my mind,
as,
as someone who's very much a junior varsity with all of this,
that the motivations would seem to be at least if people are speculating to get
rich,
both on the selling side and on the buying side.
So how,
how do you dig deeper than that?
And,
uh,
any examples would be super helpful.
Every buyer has behavioral characteristics for certain reasons.
Um,
so if you,
if you say,
let's say stocks,
to use a very simple example,
a typical individual,
um,
maybe mutual fund buyer will buy after something's gone up because they think
it's a better investment and they'll sell,
they'll get scared when it goes down because they'll get scared and the think
it's a worse investment.
Whereas a typical institutional investors,
there were a pension fund we'll buy when it goes down because they have to
rebalance their portfolio to keep an asset allocation mix at a certain level.
And so if they're losing money in something and making something and other,
they will balance,
rebalance in a mechanical way.
And so there are many different ways of knowing,
uh,
of,
of saying,
okay,
who are the biggest ones?
Who are the littlest ones,
you know,
but most importantly,
the biggest ones and what are they motivated to do?
And,
uh,
by,
by understanding it in that way,
um,
you know,
it's important.
So you,
you have a lot of,
a lot of different buyers and sellers in different markets for different reasons
that when you examine it,
you know,
kind of makes sense.
It somebody might end you,
you,
you'd be acquiring some stock may go public and then,
uh,
the owners have a window that they are,
it's closed for them to sell it and then the window opens up and then they're
going to sell.
At that time.
I'm just giving you a whole bunch of examples that,
um,
one can know or attempt to know,
that are more than just people wanting to make money.
Somebody squeezed,
you have,
um,
you know,
you have a financial squeeze and they need cash so that they're motivated to
sell it because they need cash.
There are lots of different reasons,
right?
Meaning a distressed seller in the last case,
right.
And to know on an ongoing basis that the market is made up of that mixture
[inaudible]
and so,
Eh,
you know,
as much as,
as much as one can is a good way of,
uh,
of getting a sense of that
very common where I'm sitting right now,
I'm in San Francisco and,
uh,
so I've,
I've read and I please correct me if I'm wrong,
but uh,
from Tony Robbins book,
which included you,
um,
that I suppose over a long enough period of time,
anyone's favorite asset class,
I'm paraphrasing this,
uh,
w will decrease by 50 to 70% or something like that.
Yeah,
that's what I said.
You okay.
Got It.
So what are the implications that the,
the,
the most important implications of that from the behavioral standpoint of
investors?
Like what,
how should that change their thinking or behavior?
Well,
it goes back to the point I was making before that you can come up with a bunch
of equally good investments.
I mean,
Gen generally speaking,
all investments are competing.
And what that means is if one was clearly better than another,
more money would go into it,
bid up its price,
and then it would be a comparably according to the marketplace.
And the marketplace is pretty smart.
In order to be successful and being a tactical,
you have to be better than the marketplace.
And that is an easy,
therefore the marketplaces pretty smart that all of those assets are going to
have roughly speaking,
comparable expected returns other than the surprises that will take place in the
future.
And you have a choice.
You're either going to be smart enough that you think you're going to bet
against somebody else,
that they're going to go up or down or you're going to diversify.
So you can take these assets and achieve a level of balance with those assets
that doesn't you an expected return but provides you a much lower level of risk.
And if you can reduce your risk and keep your expected return the same,
you got to do that.
So diversification as we were talking about before,
um,
can allow an individual I explained in that book,
I thought by the way,
was a great book,
uh,
because what Tony did was to take concepts and make them very clearly conveyed
for the average reader.
Um,
I explained,
he interviewed me in the book how to achieve that kind of balance so that you're
not going to have that because if you lose 50 or 75% of your money in a,
in a decline,
let's say 50%,
that means you need 100% return to get back
right where you started.
So you,
you can't,
uh,
you can't allow yourself to do that.
That's the risk of ruin thing.
So diversification,
proper diversification can reduce your risk without reducing your return.
There are many different ways to diversify.
How would your approach differ most if it does from say a David Swenson?
Bye.
Approaches I was describing it is to balance the risks based on the two factors
that we were,
the two determinants that we talked about before.
How are,
what are the intrinsic drivers of those?
And then also what are the timeless and universal correlations of those assets
and to it to achieve a balance.
I'm always looking for a value added risk reducing trade.
The issue is to look at the intrinsic characteristics and,
and,
and uh,
and achieve and achieve balance.
You were diversification can get very tricky in the world of say,
startup investing.
You mentioned in brief this lockup period is where someone,
I'm a perfect example of this,
has made investments that are illiquid for a period of God knows how long,
seven to 12 years in some cases.
And what started off as a plan to have say 10% of one's liquid net worth
invested into startups suddenly becomes 80% of the pie chart.
Um,
I think are you saying if you have an 80% of your portfolio concentrated
portfolio and in the one particular asset that's right.
I would urge you to find out how you're going to hedge that thing.
Yeah.
And um,
you know,
there are different ways that you can make that hedge.
You know,
to some extent it's by something,
but,
but to some extent you might go into a contract,
uh,
you know,
it could be done almost,
I don't know the nature of the particular types of investments,
but,
uh,
it's,
if it's a particular company with a particular profile that'll be unique to it.
The only way that you're going to be able to hedge that is to go into some
probably investment bank and actually explain to them their circumstances and
find out,
you know,
a structure that has,
uh,
that they might be able to come across.
It's going to be a highly impure hedge and,
uh,
you know,
it needs to be engineered.
So it,
you know,
it's a very difficult thing and because 80% of your net worth is tied up,
you can't go have the cash to go buy something that's going to balance it and
you wouldn't want to borrow and then borrow the cash too.
Buy something different because probably it's correlation with whatever you're
using as a diversifier is not going to be reliable.
And so you're,
you know,
you can really get screwed.
So I don't know that I have a good answer for that.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a tough one because like you said looking,
because I don't have anywhere close to the cash required to say take a sort of
derivative position to,
to try to hedge.
It's very challenging and like you also observe the impure nature of trying to
do any kind of secondary with a forward looking promissory note or something
like that.
In any case,
I don't want to bore people to tears,
but it's a very common problem in uh,
in silicon valley
it's difficult because it's also a liquid,
you know,
so much money is a liquid so people can be real rich on paper but pretty poor
cash wise.
I mentioned tactical and psychological.
So in a situation like this where you can't,
there is no magic answer.
There is no necessarily nonobvious solution to this.
It's just a tough position to be in where you stand to potentially lose a lot.
What do you say to yourself?
What's your self talk in a situation like that where you may just be stuck in a
position where they eat that you can't get out of,
uh,
a,
from a,
from an investing perspective?
Well,
I think of,
um,
like how bad am I going to get hurt kind of thing.
And I almost think in portfolio sometimes that it's better to take a portfolio
and you have a certain amount of cash and you think,
how bad am I going to get?
And then you could take your risk and put it in another portfolio and,
and separate the portfolios rather than to blend them together so that you're,
you know,
you're actually thinking,
okay,
how bad is it going to get?
And,
and also like,
okay,
so it's the nature of the beast and what's the big deal?
I mean,
you're going to,
you know,
when it comes down to it,
you're going to have a,
you know,
what can they take away from you so that you're going to have,
you're going to have a bed to sleep and you're going to have food.
You're going to have,
you know,
friends.
Uh,
the most basic good things and you're playing the game and it's the nature of
the beast.
So I guess that's like for me,
it's like I keep thinking what are they going to take away from me and what's it
really going to mean?
Have you ever of red,
for instance,
this book titled More Money Than God,
which I read a few years ago.
And there were a number of cases in that book of very over the long term
successful investors who had hit a point of overwhelm or such high levels of
stress that they did based on my recollection,
which could be faulty but effectively hit the reset button.
They liquidated all their positions and kind of it over.
Is that something you've ever done?
And if so,
how did you think about that?
No,
I've,
I've never done it because of stress.
um,
I've liquidated positions to take risk off the table because certain things have
happened and I'd say,
listen,
I just don't know.
And I'd rather now take a risk off the table.
But I do know of 'em one terrific investor,
uh,
who got into a very bad mindset.
I mean,
he just couldn't make anything work for a period of time.
Um,
and that started to affect his psychology that a worsened his decision making.
And what he did was he brought his positions down to such a small level,
uh,
that he was continuing to play the game.
But he,
but with amounts that wouldn't have that psychological effects until he could
get back into that mindset and get back into the groove.
Did that work for him?
That worked for him.
Psychology is a big deal in psychology is a big deal in the markets.
Um,
that's why I also find that my rule based algorithmic type of trading a rural
meaning I take a rule and a decision rule.
So it's not a,
um,
it's not,
uh,
it's,
it's just,
uh,
the algorithm is just an expression of my criteria and then I put it into an
algorithm.
But by knowing how that algorithm works and having it operate next to me,
in other words,
I'm doing my decision making in my way.
And then my,
all my thinking is programmed into the computer so that there is a parallel
decision making going on by the computer as been fabulous because that computer
and got no emotions and it's like,
you know,
I don't know,
a computer chess game,
um,
and,
you know,
and it,
and it's great and it's been a fabulous experience to have be an ed,
uh,
playing the game together.
So the taking the emotions out of it,
um,
is a real,
real plus.
And I'm a meditator so I can,
you know,
I would say,
I don't get as emotional as some people do and,
but,
but when you go through it,
because you go through a process in which you're thinking,
um,
let's say something's going against you in,
and of course trades will always go against you.
You,
it's not like you buy something and from that point forward it goes up
then sell it.
And you know,
I mean,
there's,
it's not like that.
And so,
um,
if you buy something and good value,
it might go down before it goes up.
And then when you're in your,
when you're wrestling with,
okay,
now do I sell it?
It's not like that's the moment either.
So all every moment you don't know whether you're,
are you missing something or,
uh,
are you wrong or is it just too early?
All of that psychology enters into it and you start to think about multiple
possibilities and um,
and then,
um,
you know,
okay,
there's more opportunity.
That's why the strategies I'm describing,
the combination of diversification.
So no one bat bed is going to matter so much.
So I have the casino of bets.
So yeah,
if I'm wrong on that,
but on one or here it's okay.
But that casino means all my games on balance of going to play,
pay off and,
and,
and then that,
uh,
that notion of,
um,
systemizing the decision rules.
These things have been very helpful to me.
This is a great place to,
to wrap up and I think it's,
it's a,
I'm just going to read a small piece from your book,
which I highly recommend everybody check out.
I mean,
just to give everybody an idea,
one of the testimonials blurbs on the book is from Bill Gates.
Quote Ray Daleo has provided me with invaluable guidance and insights that are
now available to you in principles.
So I think that this is going to do a lot of good in the world and help people
to make better decisions.
And here's a quick quote quote.
Every day each of us is faced with a blizzard of situations we must respond to
without principles.
We would be forced to react to all things life throws at us individually as if
we were experiencing each of them for the first time.
If instead we classify these situations,
isn't it types and have good principles for dealing with them,
we will make better decisions more quickly and have better lives as a result.
Uh,
and I,
I'm very excited to see what this book does in the world.
And,
uh,
I suppose just as,
as one of the very last question is why did you,
why,
why did you decide to put this book out?
Why now
I'm at a stage in my life where my objective is no longer to be more successful
myself.
I'm in a transition 68 years old.
And um,
I felt that my number one goal is to help people be successful without me.
And I'm having this collection of recipes that it's been built up over that
period of time and passing it along.
So that basically everything that I know is a value in the book,
um,
frees me of that responsibility and is,
uh,
what I,
you know,
feel is his sense of responsibility and I hope everybody,
I wish everybody would do the same.
Like I'd love to know,
you know,
how many people's principles would you love to know?
By the way,
I've been speaking to a number of,
I won't use the names,
but a number of 'em very successful people and I know now that they are going to
be more inclined to put their recipes out and I think it will be fabulous.
You should write your principles.
I,
you do cheerier principles in many ways,
but as there as those,
those recipes and you give these recipe books and people then can compare one to
another and debate them and operating at that principal level I think is a
responsibility that I have to do and it kind of frees me up to go to my next
stage of life.
Well,
I've been taking notes throughout this entire conversation.
I'm going to uh,
simulate my own pain button and have a number of,
of homework assignments that I'm looking forward to tackling.
And uh,
for people listening they can certainly learn a lot about the book and dig
in@principles.com they can find you on Twitter and elsewhere at Ray Daleo.
Uh,
is there anything else you would like to suggest or ask or encourage people to
do before we wrap this up?
No,
I'll just
have their own principles that they believe in and be open minded,
right?
Their principles down,
compare them with others,
find out,
be guided by principles,
be a principled person.
I would say that those things probably will help them be not only more
successful but you know,
comfortable with themselves.
Perfect.
Well rate,
I really appreciate all the time.
This has been a lot of fun for me and I've been looking forward to this ever
since we,
we met and you're so kind after
bolstering my confidence after my rehearsal at Ted.
So I really appreciate all of it in the work that you do.
You nailed it.
It was great.
We
were both like the same.
We're both nervous that we were going to do a lousy job and we both got through
it well.
So anyway,
thank you also for your,
um,
very interesting questions and the wonderful exchange.
Thank you.
My pleasure entirely.
And for everyone listening links to the book to uh,
raise a video explaining the economy.
Everything that we talked about can be found in the show notes.
I will link to everything@tim.blog forward slash podcast or you can find the
show notes for this episode and every other.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and you will get the very
next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis if I can't get what I need through whole food meals
throughout the rest of the day.
As listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can receive 30% off of your first order by visiting Athletic greens.com
forward slash Tim that is a great deal on one of my favorite products and it
covers my basis.
Each day is part of my routine and it leads you to have less to worry about.
If for instance,
I have to skip a meal or just can't get a high quality fail,
so check it out.
Go to athleticgreens.com/tim and learn all about this episode is brought to you
by four sigmatic founded by the genius Fin's who lit the Internet on fire and
the,
you may have heard of their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every day,
either that or the Chaga,
which is decaf and a separate version.
And I use both of these primarily for focus and productivity.
They just get you going let you up like a Christmas tree.
So definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer.
I try to force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing if I have employees or people come over who are working
on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because I'm going to get the limitless effect.
We get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their products sold out in less than a week.
So you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with hot water,
and oddly enough only includes 40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters,
acid reflux or any stomach burn,
any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option.
And I have a cupboard full of their products at the moment,
which is right around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something,
you can try a sample pack,
which is great.
Also right now by going to four sigmatic.com forward slash Tim,
that's four Sigmatic,
c.com forward slash Tim and use the code,
Tim,
to get 20% off of your first order and they're not that expensive anyway.
If you were in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed,
so try them out.
Yeah.